engineering flaws
what are some common things about
engineers that end up being
a detriment to the engineering process
well i've got some ideas in my head that
i'm going to talk to you about
number one i think this is a big one i
see it all the time and it's highly
frustrating
and it is analysis paralysis
this happens to a lot of us especially
with an engineering or troubleshooting
mindset because what happens is
you think of a solution
and then you begin to think of
counterpoints to that solution and
counterpoints to those counterpoints
and what you end up with is quite a few
different options and quite a large set
of pros and cons in your head
and this can cause you to freeze and
take no action at all
because you just you're just thinking
about it
now i don't know if there's a perfect
good solution to this but in general i
think what you have to do is
limit your analysis time and then pick
the best one off of that analysis but
once time's up you have to be very firm
like maybe you say i'm going to research
this for one hour i'm going to pick the
best method
by one hour set an alarm set a timer
whatever you need to do
and then just take the action so once
you have it in place like 90 of the time
i would say i guess it depends on who it
is that action you pick after a limited
research time will
be very sufficient and often the best
especially it might be the best because
you might just end up getting the thing
done and off your mind so you can move
on all right well let me know your
thoughts on the whole analysis paralysis
thing i think it's a big one and it's
one of the first things that popped into
my head when i asked the question so
let's go on to number two
number two and i'm sure this one will
cause at least a little bit of
controversy which is fine discussion is
always good how do i word this engineers
often become very passionate about a
very niche thing and i think overall
this is a trap to a limited extent and
you'll probably notice the theme by the
end of this of
me mentioning limiting things and that's
because that's just the way i handle
things so engineers will often get
caught up in
a technology or a theory or
something like that and sometimes this
is a good thing to focus on but
oftentimes
it's a rabbit hole
like how much can you really research
about black holes how many days can you
spend on researching black holes before
you just come to the conclusion that we
really don't know because that's
basically the conclusion
there's not a whole lot really to learn
but some people will go very deep into
that subject
and
the counterpoint to this is that well if
we don't know very well someone's got to
study it and that's very true
but for the majority of people you want
to wait for the experts to weigh in
because
you can't be an expert in every field
and you gotta kind of align with your
goals
if you're not doing that you're gonna
find yourself in
problematic situations where you wanna
do something but you can't seem to
acquire the skill set and i think part
of that is you've just been studying
some deep rabbit hole that doesn't
really benefit you much
and you really just need to switch and
learn the core technology so i think
that's the answer here is to stick to
the core
and this is
not something i like to say because i'm
not someone who typically
likes the most popular people although i
might it really just depends but what
you have to do here is learn the most
popular and common ways of completing
what you're trying to do for example if
you're trying to make a business
application
research the languages
don't get stuck in analysis paralysis
just do a tiny bit of research pick one
dive in you can analyze it again later
after you've made your first app with it
or whatever it is but by that time
you're going to have a ton more
knowledge and it just scales really well
when you continue to take action and go
don't get stuck in rabbit holes where
you don't learn anything
so yeah that's my second pick is
basically the
the rabbit hole problem so what is the
uh third thing now that engineers have a
often
very problematic flaw with
well for me
number three is not knowing where to
start now
this has become a lot easier in modern
times where you can google search for
guides and tutorials on any given thing
but that doesn't always suffice
sometimes you want to do something truly
unique
or
there is no documentation on it or
you'll be the first one to write a blog
on it or whatever if you actually do it
and that's not too uncommon for
engineers to run into this problem where
i want to do something but i can't even
figure out where to get started like
nobody's talking about this
i think it's important but like
where do i go and then you ask on stack
overflow it becomes a meme you get 10
down votes a bunch of people saying why
would you want to do that
that is a problem that is
a problem
that is not easy to solve all the time
if you want to do something new that you
know is difficult
i think
you have to either have an understanding
of a starting point if it doesn't click
maybe this would be like the doesn't
click problem because i think it's a
very real problem that doesn't get
talked about sometimes
a concept or something you want to do
you know what you want to do but like
how to do it won't click right away and
the way around this problem is basically
to study and rest
and study and rest
i don't think there's any real shortcuts
it does take time but basically
you have to study things that lead up to
the problem like if you want to
understand
trigonometry trying to just jump to that
is going to be so confusing if you
skipped algebra so you got to start like
building blocks
and from what i understand of
neuroscience and stuff that my limited
knowledge has i'm a computer scientist
not a neurosol
there seems to be a consensus among that
community where
you have to get deep focused study in
and then you need to rest if you don't
get the rest afterwards
that deep focused study like literally
doesn't work
and i know that sounds crazy but
that is the way it is you like need a
lot of rest some people will say no i'll
just study 24 7 until it clicks
and it will never click you'll just die
of tiredness and that's not good so but
the drive is still kind of right you
still want to like really hone in on
something spend like some really focused
hours where you know know you're not
going to get interrupted
on this thing it will build up and maybe
you won't even click the first day or
two but it's often in the morning when
you come back at it that you'll notice
that like you have a new understanding
and it's there's a reason why that's in
the morning when you come back at it
that you feel like you have a new
understanding and that like you can
finally fix that bug that you've been
staring at all day and it was actually
really simple
there's a reason that happens in the
morning and not like late at night when
you're half tired and like wired on
caffeine or whatever so yeah that's my
pick for number three i know it was a
little convoluted but i think that's an
important one so let me see if i can
conjure up
one more of this video for you guys and
please if you want to support the
channel
it would mean a lot just hitting the
like button leaving a comment
would mean a lot you could also join via
the button or patron there's a three
dollar tier that basically buys me a
coffee or a beer every month and i would
really appreciate it if you would
do that it means a lot for this channel
going forward
and
there's also like a source tier which is
kind of a higher another level number
four
the last thing probably
the last engineering thought flaw that
happens
oh i got it
okay
here's one
and i
hmm i know i know this is a good one
because it's happened to me and i've
seen people do it i've seen people
stuck in this way as engineers i kind of
want to tell a story but i don't think
the story is complete enough to tell so
i'm just going to try to explain the
problem instead what happens here is you
find a general solution
that tends to work a lot of time
for example
[Music]
this is just the one that comes to mind
so i'm thinking of cars
you find that oil is a great lubricant
for the internals of car
so you start trying to apply that to
everything you're like oh you need to
you need some uh slipperiness in there
put some oil in there
oil oil and
obviously you know that that's a
terrible solution to a lot of problems
you don't want to be cooking with motor
oil you don't want to be using it during
uh
fun time
it's it's technically correct
it's
you want you want the thing to be more
slippery just using oil is the example
here you try to apply oil motor oil to
everything but obviously that's wrong
so i think this happens a lot in a lot
of different ways that was just the
example that
came to mind but like
with programming for example say someone
says or you decide you want to build a
website but you only use one language
maybe you only use python so you decide
i'm going to
build my website python because it's a
good general solution
and sure you can you can like write a
program that like spits out the right
code or whatever for your website
but oh my
that's not a good solution
right
and i think this you know that might be
more debatable because
python being somewhat of a common server
language it might actually be a half
decent idea i'm not actually sure but
i'm willing to bet you get the point
here
that just because it's a good general
purpose answer
doesn't mean it's the answer to
everything with sort of with that
same
[Music]
problem set
in this in in real life
like
it's hard to think of more good examples
here but you can really apply this to
anything if you ask the question like
when the first planes were flown
maybe they thought hey
birds have
feathers let's put feathers
all over each of our designs
and there might be some way that that
would kind of work but obviously we know
now that we don't need to put feathers
on planes fifth problem
sometimes engineers like to have way too
much
stuff
and not
handle problems
in real life because they're too busy
working on problems in their head and on
paper
is that a real thing i have definitely
seen a lot of engineers have clutter but
i've also seen a lot a lot of them that
are like really neat and i don't
normally have clutter but
this is all temporary stuff most of it's
not even mine
so that's all i'll say about that all
right peace out guys see in the next
video
you